okay
make sure you spoon over quicker
solution only in like my house we have
our main course before our pudding yes
why would I putting names up after the
starter oh it's gonna happen listen to
me got water on the ball ready for your
broccoli okay right Kumble mix I can't
and be generated it's okay chop the
rhubarb with your crumble mix okay now
the exciting part now is that we get a
really nice amount of crumble in the
bowl it's sort of bakes in the oven and
absorbs all that kernel and you've got
this amazing delicious crumble welcome
dick you're going too fast of the
nation's slow down on top now nicely
okay like that then boiled you see
something else you're blind
no right excellent
just I took them on top Jesus Christ
okay put yours in okay put yours in okay
darling no go you down there look for
you down there why you down there
take out your summon Oh
underlings mark stares from Alex or
actually take your [ __ ] salmon out
please so I say alright a minute someone
else please bottom no that's the come
more Jesus course